ووسيله اهلا بكم في هذه النافذه للتحليل
العسكري مع اللواء فايز الدويري وسوف سده
اللواء نشاهد هذه المشاهد التي نشرتها
كتائب القسام ثم نعلق
عليها رميت رميت
[موسيقى]
ولكن
الله
[موسيقى]
اكبر
ج
[موسيقى]
جن
يا رب ما رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رمى بسم
الله يا
رب
لا
ما رميت رميت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولكن الله
اكبر
[موسيقى]
جده
جن
[موسيقى]
يا رب رميت ولكن الله رمى بسم الله يا
رب
ر
[موسيقى]
رمرم
وكن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله
اكبر
[موسيقى]
جن
جنت
يا رب ما رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رمى بسم
الله يا
رب
ي
[موسيقى]
صور قويه جدا سياده اللواء معبره معبره
ربما الاقوى منذ اكثر من 70 يوما والملفت
بدايه من الواضح ان هذه الصور هي صور
التقطت من الاسرائيليين انفسهم يعني اخذت
من الجنود الاسرائيليين
لانه قريبه جدا لا يمكن ان صوره حاوره
انقاذ حياه احد المصابين اخذت من مسافه
قريبه جدا وهذا نقطه تجمع لقوات جيش
الاحتلال لا يمكن تحت اي ظرف ان يكون احد
افراد القسام كان موجودا والتقط هذه
الصوره بهذا
الوضوح
وم مسافه قريبه جدا كذلك الاليات المط سحب
الال سحب الاليات الجندي كان يسير بجانبها
اذا هي كانت في المنطقه شبه مؤمنه من اجل
سواء اسعاف المصاب او سحب الاليات اذا هذه
اخذت من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي من قبل احد
جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي لكن السؤال المطروح
كيف وصلت الى القسام هنا ندخل في البعد
التحليلي من اخذ هذه اللقطات وهذه
الصور تم الوصول له قتله والحصول على
وبتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي لم ينشرها ولن
ينشرها انا اتحدث عن اخر الفيلم ليس عن
عمليات الاستهداف عمل الاستهداف موضوع
مختلف وبالتالي هذه الكاميرا التي التقطت
هذه الصور من مسافه قريبه جدا خاصه الجندي
لاحظ الوضوح في تقاسيم وجه المصاب فبتالي
اخذت من مسافه قريبه جدا ولكن تم الوصول
لمن كان يحمل هذه الكاميرا تم اقتناصه وتم
مصادره الكاميرا وقامت القسام بنشر هذه
الصور اذا هذه الصور كانت في حوزه الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو من التقطها ولكن نقلت الى
يد القسام من خلال عمليه المميز يمكن
القول اذا انها صادمه مرتين صادمه بسبب
المشاهد والقتلى والجرحى الموجودين فيها
وصادمه بسبب طريقه الحصول على هذه طريقه
يعني من
التقطها سقط بيد ال القسام قتيلا اسيرا
جريحا بغض النظر انما تم الوصول له
والحصول على الكاميرا ومحتوياتها وتم
عرضها وبالتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي لم لم
يتطرق لها لا من قريب ولا من بعيد لم
اشاهد ذلك ولم تقدم
ايه امور مؤكده لما حدث من قبل جيش
الاحتلال وهذا يبين ان ما يتحدث به الناطق
باسم جيش الاحتلال لا يع عكس واقع ما يجري
في الميدان هو يقدم خطابا شعبويا من اجل
تحقيق اهداف القياده السياسيه في في بصوره
عامه
وال المجتمع في داخل الكيان الاسرائيلي
مغيب عن الواقع تاتي افلام القسام
والفيديوهات لتعكس صوره مبينه كليا اذا
يعني الرساله انتم لديكم صور لما يحدث
حقيقه في الواقع ايها الاسرائيليون لكنهم
لا تعرضونها نحن حصل عليها هذا هو الواقع
الذي لا ت ن الرقابه العسكريه يعني اي شيء
يجب ان يصدر من داخل الكيان يخضع للرقابه
العسكريه هناك بعض الصحف اي يدعوت احرنوت
هارس غيرها من الصحف الكبيره ذات التاثير
الممتد داخل الكيان الاسرائيلي لديها
قنواتها يدعوت احرنوت عندما نشرت عن اصابه
5000 منهم 2000 اصابه خطره 7% يعانوا من
امراض نفسيه هي هددت باللجوء الى المحكمه
العليا في سبيل نشر هذه الارقام واعتقد ان
تم الوصول الى نقطه وسطيه هي لم تفصح عن
كل شيء البيانات اليوميه لجيش الاحتلال
قارنه ببيانات المستشفيات التي تصدر في
مساء كل يوم ما يتحدث عنه الناطق
العسكري اقل مما يتحدث عنه مستشفى واحد
مش مجموعه من المستشفيات ف نتحدث دائما
وقلنا دائما انه بانه خسائر الجيش
الاسرائيلي اضرب برقم 10 وما حديثه عن
خسائر القسام وغيرها من الفسائل المقاومه
اقسمه على ع
نعم حسنا
اذا ايضا هناك الفجوه كبيره يتحدث عن 700
ونيف من الجرحى منذ بدء العمليات البريه
ولكن ارتع احرنوت هذه الصحف نش
الاف وبالتالي اسبع نعم اذا الفجوه كبيره
جدا نحن لا نتحدث عن رقم متقارب انا اقول
ان
ماين ما يتحدث به الناطق باسم القوات
الاحتلا سنعود الى هذه النقطه اذا سمحت لي
ولكن سنشاهد مره اخرى ايذا هذه الصور التي
نشرتها كتائب
القسه رميت رميت
وكن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله
[موسيقى]
اكبر
جن
[موسيقى]
جنت
يا رب الله رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رما
بسم الله يا
رب
ي3
ت
كديمه هذه صور الجرحى والقتلى كنت تتحدث
سياده اللواء عن الفجوه الكبيره بين الاف
الجرحى كما نشرت ديعت حرنت وها ارتس وما
يعلنه تعلنه المصادر الرسميه العسكريه
الاسرائيل سيدي ما يعلنه هذه الصحف الكبرى
قلت لك لك يعني هي تخضع نسبيا للرقابه
العسكريه ليست بالمطلق ولكنها لا تشر
الحقيقه كامله لانه عندما نقول تخضع
للرقابه العسكريه نسبيا سيكون هناك نقطه
اتفاق ما بين الصحيفه وما بين
ال المراقبه
العسكريه لماذا لانه عمليه نشر الاخبار
كامله ستحدث ضجه في داخل الكيان
الاسرائيلي لكن اذا اخذنا بعض الصح
المستقلين الذين يكتبوا على
المواقع في مفارقه حدثت
تتبعت ارقام الخسائر من خلال الاليات
والمعارك وكنت اضع رقم يعني حتى حتى هذه
الصحف الخاضعه للرقابه ارقامها اكبر بكثير
من يا سيدي ارقامها تحدثوا عن 5000 قبل
عده اسابيع نعم الان ارقامها نفسها تخضع
بدرجه ما للرقابه العسكريه هكذا اقرا
المشهد نعم لماذا حدثت مفارقه تتبعت اعداد
الاليات التي تدمر وتتبعت بيانات القسام
وما ياتي من عواجل على مواقع مختلفه وكنت
اضع بصوره افتراضيه عندما يتم تدمير اليه
اي اتصور حسب طبيعه الضربه هل الضربه
قاتله هل الضربه متوسطه هل الضربه خفيفه
وبناء
على هذه المعطيات لمده 10 ايام تتبعت هذا
الحادث على مدار ال 24 ساعه بحيث حتى انه
اذا غبت عن هذه المواقع اعود واتابع والخص
ظهر عندي الرقم لا ازال اذكره وهذا في قبل
وقف اطلاق النار قبل الهدنه ظهر عندي
الرقم
1350 بين قتيل وجريح هذه
نتيجه قواعد افتراضيه
وفاج بان صحفيين من الكيان
الاسرائيلي ذكروا عن الخسائر في تلك
الفتره وكان رقمي اقل من الرقمين الاخرين
احدهم كان بحدود ال 1450 والاخر بحدود
1520 انا طلع عندي تقريبا 1350 وانا
اعتمدت قاعده العشره اوكي فبالتالي اذا
حتى ارتس ودعوت احر نوت لا تقدم الحقيقه
كامله لانه ستكون صادمه نعود مره اخرى
نعود مره اخرى الى اعلانات المستشفيات
المسائيه
ولو تتبعنا وجمعنا هذه الاعلانات
سنجدها اضعاف مضاعفه لما يعلن عنه الناطق
العسكري في جيش الاحتلال الان الفيديوهات
التي شاهدناها منذ اسابيع ونحن نشاهد
الفيديوهات لو تتبعنا هذه الفيديوهات لقطه
بلقطه وقمنا بعمليات احصاء سنجد ان
الارقام اضعاف مضاعفه علما ليس كل
العمليات تم تصويرها هل يعقل ان
في منطقه واسعه كبن سيلا ارض مفتوحه
مسافات بينيه كبيره هل القسام او غيره من
الفصائل قادرا على تصوير كل الفيديوهات من
الذي يصور الجهاد الاسلامي والقسام ماذا
عن البقيه هناك مجموعه من الفصائل كذلك
مشاركه لم تنشر اي شيء وبالتالي اذا
الارقام مضاعفه لما تنشره الصحف
الاسرائيليه وليس فقط لما ينشره الناطق
باسم جيش الاحتلال وهناك الصور التي وها
الاسرائيليون انفسهم مثل هذه الصور التي
نشاهدها ولم نرى مثيلا لها من قبل ايضا
يعني هذه الصور هي من المؤكد ستطيع الجزم
انها اخذت بكاميرات اسرائيليه دعنا ان شئ
ن نعلق عليها لقطه بلقطه هذه مثلا هي قص
ثلاث جفات مشبوكه ببعض تسحب دبابه خلفها
جارفه تدمر
بالارض من بعد هذه الدبابه ثلاث جارف
ودبابه مع جارفه بالخلف الان هذا مصاب يتم
عمليه اسعافه لا يزال فيه رمق من الحياه
هذه الصوره هل يمكن لي ان اخذها من مسافه
معينه هذا قتيل الان الان قتيل الان في
الصوره اللي قبلها والصوره هذه الصوره
اللي قبلها كان يبدو لا يزال فيه نبض هذه
لاحظ هذه استهداف دبابه من حاله
الثبات من زاويه عموديه
مجانبه هذه استهداف دبابه من حاله الحركه
كذلك من زاويه عموديه
مجانبه الله
ا هذا الاستهداف مختلف من زاويه راسيه
استهدف مؤخره الدبابه الجزء الخلفي من
الدبابه وهذه قاتله لانه الافراد في الخلف
هذه الان عمليه استهداف كذلك ناقله هذه
اربعه
مشاهد اربعه
مشاهد الان استخدام
التاند التي بي جي عفوا استخدام التي بي
جي وهي ضد التحصينات
هدف واضح تماما نعم الهدف واضح عمليه قنص
من مسافه قريبه جدا طلع تقاسيم الوجه
نعم
هذه الصوره في قمه الروعه انظر مجموعه من
الجنود يحتم بالدبابه ع او اكثر نعم هؤلاء
هي موجود فيها عشره دبابه موجود ف موجودين
بجانب الدبابه في فتره
استراحه القناص اثر ان يستهدف الافراد
لانه اذا استهدفهم الدبابه بقيت عباره عن
هيكل موجود يمكن استهدافه في اي لحظه فهو
اثر استهدام
استخدام التي بي جي ضد الا افراد هذا هذا
تشكيل يستخدم في اقتحامات المدن يمكن ان
نقول يا سيده هذه الدبابه هذه الدبابه عن
الافراد الذين رايناهم اوكي عره افراد
الدبابه الدبابه طاقمها اربعه افراد نعم
وتحمل سته افراد في المنطقه الخلفيه من من
الدبابه يصبح المجموع
عش انت قلت رقم 10 قبل ان اتحدث لك
بالتفاصيل قدرت الرقم بع وبالتالي هو
انسجم مع حقيقه ما تحمل الدبابه لكن ال
الشيء الشيء الملفت
للانتباه انه من من استخدم القذيفه استخدم
القذيفه لقتل الافراد ليس لتدمير الدبابه
لانه كانت يجب ان تكون مختلفه القذيفه نعم
الان لماذا لانه هؤلاء يبدوا الافراد طاقم
الدبابه كانوا في لحظه استراحه او ما شابه
ذلك محتمين بجانب الدبابه باعتبار منطقه
امنه لكن الان ماذا عمل قال قام بقتل
الافراد او استهدا لنقول استهداف الافراد
بغض النظر قتل او جرح او ما شابه ذلك الض
حقهم اصيبوا لانه الهدف ايضا قريب وواضح
نعم الهد انا اقول حتى يكون التحليل منطقي
وا مبني على كونسبت محدد هؤلاء عشره تم
استخدام قذيفه التي بي جي قد تكون قتلت
العشره احتمال قد تكون قتلت وجرحت قد يكون
نجه منهم ناس حتى لا اعمب بالمطلق لكن
المهم انه [__] استهدف ال الهدف يعني امامه
هدفين في نفس المكان فكان الاولويه ان
يستهدف الجنود لانه في حال استهدافهم
الدبابه تبقى نعم لن تتحرك لانه من
يستخدمها او يحركها قضي عليه او اصابته
فبالتالي لا اف ه لكن هؤلاء يختبئون ام
يستريحون يعني يستريحون في ظلها في مكان
لكن انا اود ان اشير الى نقطه انا لا احمل
المشهد اكثر من لا مما لا يحتمل اقول ان
هذه الدبابه قد تكون تم القضاء عليها في
لقطه لاحقه لكن لم تصور لانه اصبحت عباره
عن هدف ثابت مجرد وبالتالي يمكن استهدافه
في اي
لحظه هذه المركا عندما تجر هي لانه هي تزن
اطنانا عشرات الاطنان اكثر من 60 طن
وبالتالي تحتاج الى تحتاج الى اكثر من
جارفه لسحبها الان هذه الج الجارف الخلفيه
في اذا كان هناك حاجه تقوم بالدفع هذه
وهذا امر من يخدم في سلاح المهندسين او
سلاح الهندسه معتاد على هذا المنظر انا
نستخدم اكثر من جاره وهذا تخصصك نعلم ان
هذا تخصصك نستخدمهم اما بالتوازي او
بالتتالي كما ي هذه الصور برايك ماذا يمكن
ان يكون وقعها خاصه ان هي صور غير مسبوقه
نشاهد هذه الصور هذه اصابه مباشره بس ما
هي بماذا تم اصابته هل هو ب
تي بي جي هل هو نتيجه تاندم تم قصف
المركبه او الاليه التي هو فيها لكنه
اصابته مبينه يعني اكثر من اصابه في نفس
الجسد وبالتالي فارق الحياه لكن المهم في
الامر من وجهه نظري الله ان القاط الصوره
كان من مسافه قريبه وحتما من الجيش
الاسرائيلي لكن السؤال واللي اجابته
تحليليه كيف وصلت الى المقاوم
وكيف تم نشرها لانها نشرت تحت الاعلام
العسكري انا امامي الاعلام العسكري
الاعلام العسكري تابع المقاومه وهذا ما
يعيد طرح السؤال دائما عن الفرق المهول في
الامكانيات ونعلم على سبيل المثال ان وزير
الدفاع لويد اوستن يفترض انه يعني له
مؤتمر صحفي اليوم مع يوف جالانت اقوى جيش
في العالم يقف مع جيش كان يوصف بانه الجيش
الذي لا يقهر امكانيات يعني لا تضهر
امام هذه المجموعه من المقاومين يا سيدي
هذا الجيش الذي لا يقهر لا اود ان ا ابقى
اضرب امثله من التاريخ تصبح يعني مكرره
ومالو فه للمشاهد هذا الجيش الذي لا يقهر
هذا الجيش الذي لديه جسر جوي مفتوح
القواعد القواعد الامريكيه في اوروبا
تحديدا في بريطانيا في المانيا في ايطاليا
اكبر القواعد تقريبا اصبحت شب فارغه تم
نقلها تم ارسال ما معدله ثلاثه صواريخ او
قذائف مدفعيه مقابل كل قرد مقاتل في
المقاومه ما القي بمعدل 1000 طن يوميا
نتحدث عن 73000 طن من المتفجرات القي على
غزه اذا ذهبنا الى
نجازاكي 15000
طن 70 73000 لنقل 75000 من اجل المعادله
الرياضيه
القي على غزه خمس اضعاف ما القي على
نجازاكي القي على غزه ضعف ما القي على
نجازاكي وهيروشيما مجتمعتين وبالتالي رغم
كل ذلك ما هي الانجازات هذا يعود لجمله
اسباب اهم هذه الاسباب هذا الجيش لم يعتد
على خوض حرب لا متناظره وتحديدا القتال في
المناطق المبنيه هذا تعود على حروب مفتوحه
مع الجيوش العربيه كانت اوضاعها في ال 48
معظم الدول العربيه تحت الاستعمار في الس
56 كانت لا تزال مصر تحت الانتداب وعدوان
ثلاثي في 67 اوضاع الجيوش العربيه محط
تساؤل من حيث القدره القتاليه على الصعيد
العام وهنا قد يعتد يحتج البعض ان هناك ان
هناك كانت انجازات هذه انجازات فرديه
انجازات على مستوى الفصيل دعني بس اكمل
الفكره لو ذهبنا الى 73 يعني حتى اوصل
المشاهد الى حقيقه معينه الصفحه الاولى في
73 على الجبهه المصريه لا يستطيع اي ناقد
عسكري في العالم ان ينتقدها كانت في قمه
الاداء والروعه لكن ماذا جرى علت اليد
السياسيه فوق يد يد العسكر وبالتالي اصبحت
الحرب نهايتها سياسيه وليست عسكريه كذلك
في الواجهه السوريه لنذهب ابعد من ذلك حتى
2006 2006 نعم استطاع ان يدخل وصل نهر
الليط لكن اذاق حزب الله المر في في معارك
مجزره الدبابات الان دخل الى هذا القطاع
الصغير الشريط الضيق نعم لدينا و وواجه
مقاومه مؤمنه بقضيه فقط اريد ان اقول رم
رغم اعداد قوات نخبه اسرائيليه ولكن لم تح
قوات النخبه لا تم استخدامها لكن تم
استخدامها بمقاربات من بعد عسكري لماذا هو
تم حشد اربعه فرق ما بين ميكانيكيه و اليه
وفرقه
مشاه وضعت تحت قياده ما يطلق عليها فرقه
غزه تم تجميع تسعه الويه من المنطقه
الوسطى والمنطقه الشماليه وعززت ارسل قوات
النخبه كقوات ملحقه بواجبات جزئيه بقيت
القياده لمن لقاده الفرق فزج بالويه نحم
نحال و جولاني وغيره وجف عاتي ولكن واجهت
وضع مختلف هم من اعترفوا ليس انا ما اقول
قالوا واجهنا ظروف غير متوقعه واجهنا ظروف
لم نعتد عليها اذا هذا يعيد الى ما ذكرته
في البدايه هذا الجيش لم يتعود على خوض
حرب غير متناظره او حرب لا متناظره الحرب
اللام متناظره في التاريخ النصر للضعيف
والضعيف هنا كيف ينتصر اذا لم يهزم وحماس
وبقيه الفصائل لم تهزم حتى اللحظه التي
اتحدث بها
منتصره شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز
الدويري ختام هذه الفقره العسكريه الخاصه
بتداعيات الحرب على غزه نعود الى غرفه
الاخبار لمتابعه التغطيه مع السي ابي عاصي